tout d'abord réal bossé en pleine
pandémie comment vous vivez ça en tant
qu'artiste en tant que professionnel
d'ensemble mais ce que je trouve
inquiétant c'est que ça va pas ça en
prend du temps avec ça et on est les
collines de saison je reviens sur lol
par exemple où il ya des gars dit ça
fait onze ans il affrontait manning mois
commence à travailler là dessus et il ya
comme un réflexe conditionné alors on
pense pas à se protéger on pense à
ramasser le fils a toujours pas tantale
et ses boîtes souvenirs se pourra faire
un autre collie chemise et la
maquilleuse cinéma king est donc enfin
comme déloyaux d'un côté donc je sais
pas si ça va revenir sans pente du temps
j'ai l'impression
je pense je saute et a très jeune dider
il y aura pas de rassemblement avant
qu'elle moitié singles qui aura pas un
vaccin
je pense que les gens vont avoir une
certaine chien aussi une certaine peur
alors qu'ils vont vouloir aller
s'enfermer dans un théâtre avec des gens
tout le tour des autres mais même un
mail de distance et ce sera quoi le
ratio de la salle vous êtes issu d'une
famille de 14 enfants vous êtes le 13e
donc vivre différemment en marge des
autres et s'organise avec les moyens du
bord vous êtes habitué à son à quelque
sorte nous on était là sur une firme
donc on est à peu près je dirais un
mille 2000 ennemis du village mais on
vivait en autarcie presque on n'avait
pas besoin de grand chose on aurait pu
et on pouvait très bien décider que
enfermé offert leur appui on est
autonome on n'avait pas besoin de lait
de beurre don lever tout seuls a déclaré
en masse on avait un immense jardin est
l'équivalent de 2,3 je dirais de tout ça
je sens les patates et maïs la 3d les
basques
[Musique]
des fois je parle de ça déjà ils ont mon
âge qu'ils font quand même mon dieu
c'était la maison après oui bah oui
vraiment non je vais vous expliquer
c'est moi et ne pas retenir des
survivalistes c'est drôle parce que ça
me fait penser à votre personnage de
survivalistes dans le film jusqu'au
déclin c'est le premier film québécois
produit par netflix vous est-il
comédiens tout désigné pour jouer dans
ce film je sais pas je sais pas parce
que souvent il ya des gens qui arrivent
à bien mentir c'est ce qu'ils font pour
moi un acteur c'est un bon menteur un
bon acteur c'est un immense moteur puis
très génial donc des fois faut s'enlever
une personnalité a pas besoin d'être
dans le personnage
et des fois les gens qui tiennent à se
cherche la vérité - la vérité au cinéma
moi je pense que la fiction au cinéma et
plus intéressante parce qu'on peut
imaginer un autre puis on peut devenir
meilleur qu'un vrai professionnel en
faisant un vrai beau faux semblant donc
sur pied près monde qui aurait joué
alain mais je t'aime très content que ça
tombe ce monde
on s'entend là c'est pas des sentiers
pour la promenade
vous avez parlé de créations avec vos
mains mais est ce que cette pandémie
vous faire sacrer avec votre tête je
sais pas - une troisième saison de 19,2
par exemple je lance une perche comme ça
et quand j'ai parlé avec claude deffaugt
si longtemps parce qu on a fait un truc
qui s'appelle le tricheur et on y et z
même mis la pression
très rapidement on s'est dit il ya une
suite à 19,2 les faits moi j'avais une
bonne idée pour lui la main les dix ans
un film juste moi c'est ça pourrait
faire un film c'est finir ça parce que
le vélo est en prison pour un étudiant
chez à poil et son cerveau mais il y
aurait une version version film
cinématographique avec pas ah bah ça
serait fun mais ont tout ce feu toutes
ces pubs et des roches y avait quoi une
quarantaine d'années à l'époque leur
faudrait que ce soit au bout de 10 ans a
fait dix ans il pourrait sortir de
prison et manger des voiliers en a donné
ils y ont peut-être besoin lui pour un
cas particulier il y aurait une
possibilité d'être scénario il y aurait
il y aurait vraiment de quoi tu t'es pas
là dedans mais mais la créativité
évidemment j'écris j'écris encore à
brassac des gens ont un travail parfait
système ça marche c'est qu'ils ont des
notes puis on avance des projets j'ai
des petites s'en viennent on va faire
des petits internet en fait chacun chez
soi
donc il ya encore cette volonté de créer
des histoires je m'ennuie de la troupe à
ce que l'on avait une saison la saison
et apporter
donc c'est aussi j'ai hâte de voir qu'en
savoir prendre parce que c'est un banc
d'essai magnifique
pas que geiger de voir jean d'amour
sortie au jardin ma demande
réal bossé quelle générosité merci
beaucoup pour cette entrevue merci bonne
chance et bonne chance à vous payer 5 1
5 minutes très efficace et tout ça mord
donné plein d'idées 19,2 on n'oublie pas
19 de la fesse 9 de galaxies et donc
série attendent mais n'en a pas fini
[Rires]